it's hard to figure out just what
elevates an actor's performance into
greatness sometimes it's a commitment
other times its technical skill the
sheer ability of a performer to portray
the subtleties and nuances of a
challenging character often the right
role simply fits an actor like a glove
and occasionally if everything plays out
just right all these things can happen
at once making for some of the greatest
moments in movie history these are a few
of those moments becoming less than
human there's a tremendous degree of
difficulty in performing the role of a
human stripped of their humanity someone
whose soul has been ravaged to the point
of no return and no actor has managed it
quite like Choi min-sik in Park
chan-wook's brutal masterpiece Oldboy
choice stars as oh dae-su a man out for
revenge after being imprisoned in a
hotel room under mysterious
circumstances by unknown forces there's
a little recognizable humanity and
dae-su when he first emerges from his
makeshift prison and what remains has
been stripped away by the film's climax
choice crepes down into the absolute
depths of the human soul and offers a
turn which audiences will likely never
forget no matter how much they'd like to
[Music]
digging deep Gavin O'Connor's 2011 drama
warrior is one of the unsung triumphs of
the decade what could have been a
glorified lifetime cable drama instead
turned out as a heart-wrenching story
about fathers sons and brothers joel
edgerton and nick nolte delivered their
own remarkable performances but it was
Tom Hardy who really made the movie what
it is
Hardy's character Tommy is a raw exposed
nerve of a human being ravaged by trauma
guilt and hate party masks the
character's confusion sadness and fear
with the shield of brashness that
deflects every friendly hand that comes
his way
it's a testament to Hardy's own talents
that his character never becomes
outright unlikable
despite the script giving us every
reason to hate him - some of their parts
even the most stellar ensemble casts are
out shown by one or two standout
characters pulp fiction has Vincent and
Jules the usual suspects is very much
verbals story but the best ensemble
movies are defined by a cast of
characters who all excelled together
it's rare but it happens and The
Breakfast Club is the best example of
this kind of movie it's impossible to
pinpoint a single performance among the
main cast is the best not only because
they're all just so good but because
removing one piece of the ensemble would
bring everything tumbling down now it's
eight you stay out of it excuse me sir
at seven
shut up peewee some of the finest teen
stars of the 1980s were brought together
to form the eponymous Breakfast Club
including Molly Ringwald Anthony Michael
Hall Emilio Estevez Judd Nelson and Ally
Sheedy each cast member works in perfect
tandem with the other four and every
character receives equal focus there's
no lead or standout actor and the result
is a collective performance that's
nothing less than magical nearing the
breaking point
in do the right thing Spike Lee's Mookie
is a man adrift caught in his day-to-day
life between working for a family of
racist Italian Americans and his
friendship with other in creve coeur can
Americans Mookie is a character driven
by a powerful and almost unresolvable
frustration Leigh takes the character on
a journey from selfish passivity to
insatiable fury channeling the
characters anger and slowly building
towards an inevitable breaking point
[Applause]
his performance was one of the best of
the decade and is as powerful today as
when the movie was first released
[Music]